just to give you an example of the
contribution editor makes you know the
scene where preach comes home and and
he's in his pajamas and his mother comes
in and says go get that belt Yeah right
right well she was not an actress she
was one of the community people right
and I kept shooting the scene over and
over and over again and she she finally
said I'm tired I ain't doing it no more
and and Kris putting that in that moment
is the honest moment okay did you guys
ad-lib it all once the script was done
it was a heavy man that whole scene in
the arm you see us in the car when the
car we stole the car and what happened
is that um Glenn is nuts
okay he's totally nuts and I'm driving
like the last maniac that was for real
not like today they would take a car and
they would put it on a on a mount and
they would put cameras now this is
low-budget man we had the big cameras on
the hood three of them looking at us a
big generator in the back lights lights
we had big microphones and might have to
trust us with more walkie-talkies to
give us action and so forth so we're
doing the scene and we're going through
it and Glen's driving crazy and so forth
and Norman is next to me and Rick is in
the front and Norman got so excited he
forgot to call Glenn preach he's got his
saying you go to France Glenn plead you
gotta slow their movies just crack it up
Michael was real loose with us you know
he let us be and he like comfortable
with how he directs you here come on say
oh don't do that
well me the funniest part of that whole
thing is that the end where he crashed
her back in the car and the guys said
whiplash and the girl say lay down fool
[Laughter]
see what I figured that line that I fall
out that lying alone and that image
makes me get so many layers you know the
movie is so layered and twist and turn
and Twitter I mean you know let me I
don't want to nobody said with that with
the whiplash thing you know you let it
go because in the script what the guy
said it once
it just said whiplash but this this
comedian brother he got you just let him
go I'll be honest off camera rolling man
totally funny and quick historical note
for everybody when when I finished
working with with Eric
we took the script after a month's work
back to AIP
gave it to the executives they looked at
it and I got the best note that I've
ever gotten in my career from one of the
executives who said yeah this is pretty
good now take it back home and rewrite
every scene in a way that you have never
seen before
nice and I said what yeah and then I
thought I said hmm the the letter from
Cochise was written that he finds it on
the dresser and Brandon when he was a
toddler had this habit of putting things
in the toilet and I said and it finally
hit me okay
this is a way that nobody's ever seen
before
Wow and so I then I put him in the movie
to do his thing you know
he was good he was good every take